let's talk about how the narrative of
Africa is being told and who is doing
the telling I want to share with you the
selection of work by contemporary
artists from Africa and it's Despero I
love this arts I find it beautiful and
inspiring and thrilling and I really
hope I'm able to pique your interest I
want to share something about myself and
why art matters to me I'm the daughter
of an artist so that means that growing
up I had the chance to see my father do
art work in his studio my home was
surrounded by arts and I had an early
art education being dragged to museum
and exhibition over the summer holidays
what I did not understand really at the
time is that it also gave me an early
understanding about why art is important
how to look at it how to understand it
but also how to love it
so art matters to me on a personal level
and not only because it's beautiful and
inspiring and thrilling but because our
tell powerful stories all these artists
have stories to tell you about what it
means to be African stories that tell
you and touches about our African
identity but also stories that tell us
about who we are as African but also
stories that tell us about our complex
history so how can art tell you powerful
stories I want to share with you this
theory by Senegalese the artist omar
victor job this is a serie of
self-portraits and the artists in this
particular theory is focusing on the
representation of african in her art
history between the 15th to the 19th
century i want to show you how with one
image job is able to touch on our
african identity on the politics of
representation but also on our social
value system in this particular
self-portrait job is actually
referencing another port
it's by ana-lucia ho day this picture is
doing a portrait of rabbits is Bailey
rhombus Bailey was a nut sieve of
Senegal a former slave of Haiti but
during his lifetime he also was elected
to represent the colony at the 3rd
government of the French Revolution and
he advocated strongly for the abolition
of slavery what is very smart and clever
about job here is that he's going back
to history
he's reclaiming this figure by restaging
this beautiful you know world ooh
uniform where his restaging also the the
pose and he's doing that too actually
underlying issue that are still
impacting individual of color today
there was nothing special but this very
typical political portrait of the time
except that for the first time an
individual of color in that case
jean-baptiste Bailey was actually named
and acknowledged in her painting what
job is adding to this picture is this
crucial element which is the football
under his arm and by doing that job is
actually touching at our hero-worship
culture of african football stars who
unfortunately despite their fame their
immense talent and their royalty statues
they are still invisible job is asking
us to dig deeper to go beyond history
and what has been written and basically
see how it still influences and
impacting us in the present I want to
share this other beautiful theory called
cash angels by artist Hasan Hajj so in
this particular series the artist is
really pushing on the boundaries of
stereotype and cliche Hassan Hassan is a
friend and honesty I admire him dearly
but this particular serie is talking to
me directly as a Muslim woman I
experienced this all the time where you
know people have a lot of expectation
religious one and cultural ones but what
I love about this artist is that he's
putting all this on its head he's
actually challenging every
representation of Muslim Arabic woman
that there is Hassan Hodges is in a
child of the jaspera
he grew up in Morocco amongst you know
brights
logo goods you know counterfeit original
being sold at the Suk's so to see those
symbols you know representing in his
work a celebration of the global
cultural critic of the global urban
culture is no surprise but really at the
heart of his work is his desire of a
nuanced representation he want us to
interrupt ourself and all the perception
that we might have on people on a
culture and an environment and for
example this particular picture your
common association would be you know
certain street brand for certain western
distinctive consumer well he mashes it
all up where he is daring to imagine a
female biker culture where actually
Chanel or Louie Vuitton is designing the
djellaba and Nike Baboosh and this is
actually the standard uniform what I
love about the woman and cash angels is
that they are able to hold your gaze
we are completely participating in the
image but they are the one inviting us
in and in their own terms
Hasaan higher education jewels our
project as for a bio Mavericks our job
offer me two strong example why art is
so instrumental it is instrumental as it
really inspired us to ask questions but
it is also instrumental because it
ignite change seeing diversity in race
and ethnicity in contemporary art is the
only way that we'll see changes in the
art industry but also for the relation
between Africa and the Western canon how
we will participate and all this is
really up to us there's a lot of
progress to be made
and honestly we still need to support
stronger voices as they are the one
shaking things up and bringing new
perspective I want to share those
beautiful old painting by younger
emerging artists could deny violet how
ami for me when I see her work it really
represents freedom how I me has a
fantastic takes on you know what it
means to be an African and an African
life she has lived in three different
countries Zimbabwe South Africa and
Britain and therefore has been
influenced by a multitude layers of
communities and call
from LGBT to echoed Cosatu mo to British
cultures and as she says herself the
beauty of being a child of the jaspera
is really being able to reinvent
ourselves and what it means to be
African I want to leave you with this
powerful piece by South African artist
lo hasta maana lajas mama now also
criticized you know the influence of the
media on our moral consciousness and
he's doing that by using you know those
fabrics like banners in political
demonstration where he asking us to
reclaim our voices I believe in the
transformative power of Arts as it is
our only way to paint an image a nuanced
image of Africa but also its jaspera one
that will be painted by its artists and
its cultural producers with their
radical but also very unique view of
seeing the world and their place in it
it is really through art that we can
regain our sense of agency and
empowerment it is through art that we
can really tell our own story so likely
hasta maana says the power is ours thank
you